Die größte Bedrohung, die vom Weltall ausgeht
ist wohl der unzählige Weltraumschrott, der
um die Erde kreist.
Darunter sind nicht nur etwa 3.000 inaktive
Satelliten, sondern auch Raketenteile und
sogar eine Discokugel.
Sie alle sind mit einer hohen Geschwindigkeit
von bis zu 30.000 Kilometern pro Stunde unterwegs
- und das unkontrolliert; Sie könnten die
ganze Raumfahrt durch eine Katastrophe stoppen.
Jetzt soll endlich gehandelt werden.
Wie, was warum?
Clixoom Science & Fiction, Hier gibt es täglich
faszinierende Wissenschaftsvideos.
Abonniert den Kanal.
Nur dann verpasst ihr nichts. herzlich willkommen!
Das, was da um unsere Erde rast, ist quasi
eine Müllkippe.
Weltraumschrott wird oft unterschätzt - mit
fatalen Folgen.
Denn die Gefahr wird immer größer.
Nach Angaben des Branchenverbandes “Satellite
Industry Association” hat sich die Anzahl
der Satelliten im All in in den letzten fünf
Jahren um 50 Prozent erhöht.
Und fest steht: Der Weltraumschrott hat eine
gigantische Zerstörungskraft.
Schätzungen zufolge kreisen mehr als 20.000
Objekte mit einem Durchmesser von mindestens
zehn Zentimetern um unseren Planeten - und
das unkontrolliert.
Hinzu kommen etwa 750.000 kleinere Müll-Teilchen,
die etwa ein Zentimeter groß sind und von
der Erde aus nicht zu erkennen sind.
Sie sind eine riesige Gefahr und können das
Kessler-Syndrom auslösen, dass unsere Zivilisation
um Jahrzehnte zurückwerfen wird.
Das Kessler-Syndrom startet durch einen Crash.
Innerhalb von Stunden werden ein Großteil
der Satelliten rund um die Erde zerstört,
inklusive der Internationalen Raumstation
ISS.
Immer wieder schlittern wir an dieser Katastrophe
vorbei.
Es gab bereits 200 Kollisionen im Orbit der
Erde und jede produziert wieder neue Schrottteilchen.
Inzwischen geht man von etwa 170 Millionen
Trümmerteilen aus, die um die Erde schwirren.
Wir sind im Moment quasi Zeuge eines Kessler-Syndroms
in Zeitlupe.
Spektakulärer Höhepunkt. 2009 stoßen der
Iridium 33 des Iridum-Satelittentelefonnetzes
Gewicht eine halbe Tonne und der russische
Satellit Kosmos 2251 zusammen.
Bei einer Aufprallgeschwindigkeit von rund
40.000 Kilometern bleibt von beiden Satelliten
nichts mehr übrig außer rund 100.000 Schrottteilen.
Dabei wurde eine Energie von etwa zehn Tonnen
TNT-Sprengstoff freigesetzt.
Bedingt durch die Höhe ihrer Umlaufbahn wird
es wohl rund hundert Jahre dauern, bevor sie
in der Atmosphäre verglühen.
Und selbst solche kleinen Müll-Teilchen können
große Schäden verursachen.
Treffen Müll-Teilchen auf Satelliten-Module
kommt es zur Korrosion - die vorzeitige Alterung
der getroffenen Module ist nicht mehr aufzuhalten.
Doch das ist noch nicht einmal der Worst-Case,
denn selbst Schrott-Teilchen von einem Zentimeter
Größe können Satelliten auch auf einen
Schlag komplett zerstören.
Dazu der Chef für der Abteilung Weltraumtrümmer
bei der ESA Heiner Klinkrad: “Wenn eine
Aluminiumkugel von gerade mal einem Zentimeter
Durchmesser auf einen Satelliten trifft, hat
sie die Energie eines Mittelklassewagens,
der mit etwa fünfzig Stundenkilometern in
ihn hineinfährt."
Klar ist: Ohne Satelliten sind wir aufgeschmissen
und können weder telefonieren noch unser
Navi im Auto nutzen.
Aber auch für Raumfahrer kann Weltraumschrott
gefährlich werden.
Im schlimmsten Fall könnten dadurch sogar
Flüge ins All unmöglich werden.
Davor hatte ein NASA-Mitarbeiter schon vor
40 Jahren gewarnt.
Bisher hatte man diese Schrott-Teilchen vor
allem durch Radare beobachtet, um gefährdete
Satelliten im Fall der Fälle rechtzeitig
umlenken zu können.
Doch nicht nur Forschungsteams weltweit, sondern
auch Unternehmen, arbeiten an anderen technischen
Möglichkeiten, um zumindest ein Stück weit
die Kontrolle über die gigantische Menge
an Weltraummüll zu erlangen.
Eine neue Idee kommt vom kanadisch US-amerikanischen
Satellitenbauer “SpaceSystems/Loral” (SSL)
und zwar plant die Firma eine Art Pannendienst
für Satelliten.
Bedarf ist da, denn wie gesagt kreisen etwa
3.000 inaktive Satelliten um die Erde.
Dazu SSL-Mitarbeiter Al Tadros: “Da werden
buchstäblich Hunderte Millionen Dollar zum
Fenster hinausgeworfen”.
Schon in zwei Jahren will das Unternehmen
ein unbemanntes Raumschiff losschicken.
Es soll nicht nur in der Lage sein, an defekte
Satelliten anzudocken und sie zu untersuchen.
Es soll sie auch betanken und reparieren können
und die gewarteten Satelliten dann letztendlich
zudem wieder in die richtige Umlaufbahn bringen.
Eine Art Abschleppwagen ist auch von der Firma
“Intelsat” geplant, die Betreiber von
50 Satelliten ist.
Auch bei diesem Konzept soll an ausgefallene
Satelliten angedockt werden, um sie dann wieder
in die richtige Umlaufbahn zu bugsieren.
Schon im kommenden Jahr wird wohl ein anderer
Testlauf starten.
Und zwar plant das japanische Unternehmen
“Astroscale”, mit Hilfe eines Magnetsystems
kaputte Satelliten und auch anderen Weltraumschrott
zu erfassen.
Das Programm von “Airbus” heißt “Space
Tug” und verfolgt die Idee, alte Satelliten
auf eine Entfernung von 200 Kilometer zur
Erde zu schleppen und sie dort verglühen
zu lassen.
All diese Unternehmen wollen mit ihren großen
Aufräum-Plänen im All natürlich auch großes
Geld machen.
Und die Chance dafür stehen gar nicht so
schlecht.
Die Wartung von Satelliten bezeichnen Einige
schon als DIE Zukunftsbranche schlechthin,
denn eine Reparatur ist deutlich profitabler
als neue Satellitenmissionen.
Zudem gibt es entsprechende Auflagen, die
das Geschäft lohnenswert machen könnten.
Bereits seit 2008 fordert Frankreich von Satelliten-Betreiber
Maßnahmen zur sogenannten “Deorbitierung”
der Raumfahrzeuge.
Sie müssen also für die Entsorgung der Satelliten
sorgen und dürfen sie nicht einfach aufgeben.
Fest steht, dass das Problem angegangen werden
muss.
Dazu Fred Kennedy von der militärischen US-Forschungsagentur
Darpa: “Wir wollen keinen Wilden Westen."
Zum “Inter Agency Space Debris Coordination
Committee” (IADC) gehören nicht nur die
NASA und die ESA, sondern auch noch zehn weitere
Raumfahrtagenturen.
Auch hier wurden Richtlinien zur Vermeidung
von Abfall durch die Raumfahrtindustrie im
All vereinbart.
Beispielsweise sollen Raumfahrzeuge bei ihren
Missionen möglichst wenig Abfall abwerfen
und Zubehör wie Adapter und Abdeckklappen
nicht mehr einfach abtrennen.
Auf unserer Erde haben wir übrigens mit einem
nicht minder schlimmen Problem zu kämpfen.
Plastikmüll macht die Erde inzwischen teilweise
unbewohnbar.
Wir müssen etwas dagegen tun!
Und ihr könnt’ das.
Abonniert den Account Getridofplastics auf
Instagram.
Dafür hier klicken.
Zwei Dinge bewrikt ihr damit!
Ihr sorgt für Reichweite für das Thema und
ihr erfahrt was es alle für Produkte ohne
Plastik gibt!
Also macht mit!
Ansonsten: Bis dann, bleibt dran!